hey 40 Sue here as far back as I can
remember I always wanted to tell you
about gangsters
[Music]
like it or not Mafia mythology is
murderously melded with the history of
modern America to some the mob
represents an aspirational way of life
full of girls guns and glamor but there
is of course a much darker side this is
after all an organization that relies on
fear to get what it wants and is more
likely to resolve disputes with a bullet
behind the ear than a quiet word in it
whatever your take on lacoza Nostra
they've played an undeniable role in
shaping our culture after all which of
us doesn't have a favorite mob movie and
who can't misquote a piece of iconic
Dialogue on command see the opening of
this video through an example but where
did it all begin this Obsession of ours
well when it comes to the extraordinary
rise and fall of the mafia in America it
can all be traced back to the so-called
five families these powerful Clans Ran
New York City for decades making money
from legitimate businesses whilst also
profiting from illegal gambling
protection rackets and contract murder
in doing so they established a blueprint
which would see organized crime spread
across America and perhaps even have a
hand in the death of a president trust
me if you think your family is bad wait
until you get a load of this slot
the origins of the mafia can be traced
back to the 18th century and the Italian
island of Sicily if Italy is a boot
Sicily is its amputated toe over the
years Sicily has been ruled by many
different foreign Invaders everyone from
the Romans to the French
but eventually boot or no boots the
people grew sick and tired of being
kicked about and so they banded together
the groups they formed slowly evolved
into private armies who in time grew so
powerful they could extort money from
the very landowners who were supposed to
be controlling them
these armies became known as families
Each of which had its own secret codes
and ways of meeting Out rough Justice in
the late 19th and early 20th century a
great many Italians emigrated to the
United States in search of a better life
this included a large number from Sicily
where poor economic and social
conditions made the treacherous trip
across the Atlantic seemed like an
attractive option many of these new
arrivals settled in New York
particularly a spot on the Lower East
Side of Manhattan that came to be known
as Little Italy for obvious reasons of
course it wasn't long before criminals
from the old country began to exploit
this burgeoning immigrant population
across the pond the notorious Five
Points gang founded by former boxer
Paolo vaccarelli emerged in 1890 and
terrorized New York for 30 years
meanwhile spawning gangsters who will go
on to be some of the most feared crime
bosses ever including Maya Lansky Bugsy
Siegel and even old Scarface himself Al
Capone in 1920 prohibition hit America
and surprisingly telling people they
could no longer drink alcohol went down
about as well as turning up to a high
school fancy dress party as Jimmy Savile
the U.S government might have believed
it was a brilliant idea but the general
public most certainly did not and it was
boom time for anyone who could Supply
bootleg booze this was the iconic era of
trench coats and Tommy Guns as
upstanding crime Fighters like Eliot
Ness battled the mob on the Mean Streets
of New York and Chicago Prohibition in
the U.S coincided with the rise of
fascism in Italy as Benito Mussolini
came to power now a tolerant attitude
towards crime or indeed anything really
is not in the brief of a dictator and
Mussolini came down hard on the mafia
causing a large number of its members to
head to America
this perfect storm of a major business
opportunity and lots of new recruits saw
the American Mafia grow in size and
strength throughout the 1920s for the
most part A Man by the name of Joe the
boss maseria was running things in those
days but a powerful Sicilian Mafia Don
wanted to take over so he sent his
Protege Salvatore maranzano to make a
big bid for power in the Big Apple
madanzano gradually built up his own
criminal Empire before declaring all-out
war on Missouri in 1930 for over a year
the two New York mafia Clans openly
fought one another with gang members on
both sides guns down in the streets on a
number of occasions eventually on the
15th of April 1931 mazaria himself was
killed in a restaurant by four gunmen
person who'd arranged this mealtime
murder was none other than his own
right-hand man Charles Lucky Luciano
lookie was a gangster to his very core
as a teenager he cut his teeth in the
Five Points gang before making his
fortune in bootlegging and he got his
nickname after surviving a knife attack
that left him with a drooping guy and
distinctive scars across his face when
Luciano realized the war was going badly
he just switched sides betraying his
boss on the condition that if madanzano
emerged Victorious Luciano himself would
be made second in command upon winning
marinzano promptly reorganized the mafia
Gangs of New York into the so-called
five families in a bid to consolidate
his Newfound power he then named himself
Capo dicapi the boss of all the bosses
but this snazzy title didn't go down all
right well with the heads of the five
families they already disliked madanzano
who they saw as greedy arrogant and all
fashioned and the attempted paragraph
proved to be the literal last nail in
his coffin four Hitmen posing as
government agents went to marinzano's
office disarmed his bodyguards then made
sure that he too would be sleeping with
the fishes once again it was Lucky
Luciano who set up the hit you know I'm
beginning to think that he can't be
trusted at all whilst the world coming
to win a Mafia Boss can't be taken at
his word
anyway with both of the old school
bosses now out of the way it was time
for the mafia modernizers to have their
turn
given that he'd so ably got rid of the
two previous big dogs it would have been
reasonable to assume Lucky Luciano
himself would take the throne and
declare himself the new boss of bosses
but he didn't
In fairness having personally ordered
the murders of the previous two
incumbents he knew all too well how
dangerous it was to be the mafia's
headhunter
so instead he established something
called the commission which was made up
of seven Mafia leaders including the
heads of all the five families and would
be responsible for overseeing the
activities of the mob and mediating
dispute between rival gangs they met
every five years to Iron Out major
problems and just generally put the
organization into organized crime now if
there's one thing you don't expect from
the mafia it's high level admin putting
horses heads in people's beds sure we're
all on board with that but a HR
department that's just weird with a
solid structure in place and War behind
them for now the fire family started to
move to a whole other level
but as alcohol was decriminalized once
again they needed to look for fresh new
avenues to make money the traditional
money Spinners like rubbery extortion
loan sharking and money laundering all
continued as normal but it was time to
diversify the family business so they
infiltrated the labor unions which
allowed them to establish themselves in
Industries like construction Trucking
and the career of choice of Tony Soprano
Waste Management in the 1940s the city
of Las Vegas was starting its meteoric
rise to become the greatest Center of
Vice on God's green earth despite being
on the opposite Coast to the five
families traditional stomping grounds
the promise of profits proved too pretty
to pass up they bankrolled a number of
casinos as Sin City swelled and would
skim money from the huge sums of cash
taken on the floors every night a scam
forced to have netted them hundreds of
millions of dollars for decades it
seemed as though the mafia was
Untouchable their Code of Silence known
as omerta meant that members were sworn
to secrecy and forbidden to cooperate
with police under fear of death
infiltrating the families was
practically impossible because
allegiances often went back generations
to the same small towns in Italy the U.S
government seemed woefully behind the
curve as the mob continued to grow in
both power and numbers
but then slowly law enforcement started
to fight back
in 1950 a special committee was set up
to investigate the existence of
organized crime and it held hearings in
14 cities across the country including
testimonies from over 600 Witnesses
the hearings were televised at a time
when TV was just starting to take off
and it was the first time most Americans
had even heard anything about this
shadowy organization which seemed to
exert influence over huge swaves of
their country so what are they
paid by tax
all of this attention was obviously bad
news for the mob but if the 50s started
poorly for the mafia it was nothing
compared to how it ended in 1957 a
meeting was arranged in the small town
of Apalachin in Upstate New York it took
place at the house of a man known as Joe
the barber this coming together of the
Clans was a national Mafia meeting with
more than 100 important crime bosses and
a sorted henchmen in attendance to
discuss all kinds of Nefarious
activities and one can only assume have
a bloody good catch-up whilst they were
at it
the problem was that appalachin was
little more than a hamlet the sort of
place where big news would usually be
the mum and pop store on Main Street
running out of milk so when numerous
flash cars arrived and deposited large
numbers of extremely well-dressed severe
looking gentlemen in the middle of town
the local police force couldn't help but
Wonder just what the hell was going on
they raided the property causing the
highly unusual and not a little
humiliating scene of dozens of gangsters
running away to hide in the nearby Woods
an amazingly this shrub-based
counter-intelligence tactic didn't work
and 60 of them were arrested Not only
was this a very embarrassing incident
for the mafia but it once again shed
light on what was supposed to be a top
secret organization although any sense
of secrecy would completely evaporate
just two years later in 1959 a mobster
called jovalaki was convicted of drug
trafficking and sentenced to 15 years in
prison
whilst inside he murdered a fellow
inmate a move that saw his sentence
extended to life behind bars with no
chance of parole clearly the prospect of
eating slop from a tray and trying
really bloody hard not to drop his soap
in the shower didn't thrill volacki
because in 1963 he agreed to testify
about his time in the mop this was the
first time a made man had ever taken the
stand and publicly admitted the mafia
existed let alone got into details about
its structure and activities the Lackey
even went as far as to name many current
and former gangsters including bosses of
the major families the Lucky's hearing
was part of a crusade by Attorney
General Robert Kennedy who'd made it his
personal mission to Target organized
crime he did a brilliant job of it too
with mobster convictions Rising 800
percent during his time in office that's
one of the reasons some people believed
the mafia played a major role in the
Assassin nation of his brother President
John F Kennedy in November 1963. seismic
though the killing of President Kennedy
was it couldn't stop the events that the
lackey's confession had set in motion
several laws were subsequently passed by
Congress to give the FBI greater power
to tackle the mafia head-on the most
groundbreaking being the so-called RICO
Act of 1970. the ACT essentially made it
illegal to be part of a quote ongoing
criminal Enterprise regardless of
whether or not you were actually caught
committing any crimes that made it
significantly easier to convict known
Mobsters but more importantly it
suddenly made it possible to go after
mob bosses who were unlikely to ever get
directly involved in the Dirty Work
their organizations were built on the
thinking was that this would mean more
convictions and longer sentences and boy
did it work
the man at the spearhead of this
Revolution was U.S attorney Rudy
Giuliani and he wasted no time wreaking
Rico havoc in 1985 he brought the heads
of three of the five families to trial
using the RICO statute in what was
dubbed the case of cases and it turned
out to be a case of Giuliani one five
families zero as all three mob bosses
were sentenced to 100 years in prison it
set a precedent for the next 30 Years
with Mafia bosses frequently given major
jail time when brought to court as part
of a RICO investigation and as
surveillance became more sophisticated
the FBI also increasingly used wiretaps
to ensnare Mobsters faced with huge
sentences and often having incriminated
themselves on tape anyway more and more
gangsters conveniently forgot about
their oath of silence and happily sang
like canaries in order to spend less
time time Behind Bars even those in the
mafia who seemed Untouchable were
eventually well touched John Gotti was
nicknamed the Teflon Don because nothing
ever seemed to stick to him a flashy
dresser who actively caught in publicity
when he took over as head of the Gambino
family in the mid-80s it was the richest
of the five families with an annual
income of half a billion dollars but
after years as the most flamboyant and
famous gangster in New York his best
friend and underboss Sami the ball
gravano testified against him and in
1992 gossy was sent to prison for life
with no possibility of parole he died in
jail in 2002 with the balance of power
having now tipped firmly in the favor of
the federal government the influence of
the mafia continued to dwindle and the
decline was only compounded by increased
competition from other gangs including
the Russian mafia same name Furrier hats
but that doesn't mean that America is
now kosa Nostra free in fact far from it
the attack on 911 saw a huge switch in
the FBI's focused from organized crime
to terrorism with some Mafia task forces
dropping from around 400 agents to as
few as 20 which inevitably gave the
mafia more room to breathe
as recently as 2019 the FBI estimated
that there were still as many as 3 000
active members of the mafia in the US
and the legendary five families continue
to operate to this day so whilst it's
fair to say that the Glory Days of the
American Mafia are far behind them
when it comes to the Mob only a fool
would say that you should forget about
it
thanks for watching